what's happening how are you  I mean your husband then we got married  14 years ago  you had an accident you have problems  remembering things what things  everything  it's dr. nasch admittedly this isn't a  run-of-the-mill doctor-patient  relationship seeing you without your  husband's knowledge I want you to keep a  visual diary to hold on to your memories  my name is Chris David Lucas as I sleep  my mind will erase everything that I  know everything that I did you must be  days when you say I can't go through  this again sometimes in the truth is  painful or complicated I don't have the  strength  she's like it was blood  who did this to me no wonder I wonder  yeah he says he's protecting you but  don't trust him this isn't just about  you